and it seemed to me this the stupidest
problem you could conceivably imagine
that led to the most complicated answer
you could conceivably imagine I was in
Cambridge I finished a lecture course
two lectures early and then I sort of
hinted you know I said the University
regulations are something demand that I
turn up on Friday but you don't have to
turn up on Friday and I thought they'd
taken the hint because when I get to the
classroom it was usually in a classroom
with 150 people in it you can usually
hear some chatter and so on but it was
all quiet and then I opened the door and
they said surprise and they equipped it
all for a party some of the girls were
nice long party dresses none of the boys
wore long party dresses or if they did
they were indistinguishable from girls
and and but anyway one of them came up
to me with this problem
he said 1 1 1 2 1 1 2 1 1 and I gathered
that I was supposed to guess what came
next and I didn't succeed it says 1 1 1
2 2 1 and he looked at me and I still
didn't guess that 3 1 2 2 1 1 and I knew
from the way he was saying it that
somehow I was supposed to be able to
guess I still didn't 1 3 1 1 2 2 2 1
anyway it was quite interesting in this
party but I didn't guess and I suppose I
should cut the story short a little bit
in the end he had to tell me so there's
no need to be embarrassed if you didn't
get through
what's this sequence consists of one no
how many ones one one oh yes what's this
next sequence consists of oh two ones
oh yes that's right this next one is 1 2
followed by 1 1 oh yes 1 1 1 2 2 1 you
get the rule
and that's quite an interesting sequence
and I was just going off at the end of
term and on the plane to Boston I think
I was going to I fiddled with this and
came up with a really rather remarkable
conclusion on average each of these
sequences is about one point uh I hope
I'm getting it right one point three
five seven times the the one before it
I mean not exactly but it gets closer to
being this fixed number times the length
of the one in front of it so it gets
bigger and bigger and bigger by powers
of one point three five seven all the
time and I proved that that number I
hope I've got it right by the way was an
algebraic number don't worry if you
don't know what that means of degree 71
and it seemed to me this the stupidest
problem you could conceivably imagine
that led to the most complicated answer
you could conceivably imagine anyway
that's been called by some people look
and say sequence I call this I go the
little paper about is in the
undergraduate magazine of Cambridge and
I called it the weird and wonderful
chemistry of audio active decay audio
active because you say this and then in
some sense the structure decays although
the things getting longer all the time
and it's like radioactive and I showed
that there are some sequences in fact if
I go one step further or maybe two steps
further that 1 1 1 3 2 1 3 2 1 1 yes
this is it if I take
pants so that you can see it more easily
I'm putting a red spot there it turns
out that if you develop this sequence
here it always ends in a two because you
know you've got one two at the end of
this next time here you've got maybe
it's two tools I don't know but anyway
it'll be twos so the the left-hand
sequence always ends in a two and the
right end sequence will look it goes one
one one three one two something rather
and then 3 1 1 3 1 1 and then 1 3 2 1 1
3 etcetera and then 1 1 1 3 1 2 and here
will this sequence and this sequence we
begin in the same way and you can see
that so this sequence will begin 3 1 1 3
and so on and this is one feature what
I'm trying to say is that this will
always begin with a 1 or a fee and I
remarked before this always ends in the
two so what's interesting about that is
if you follow this sequence as if it's
always and you follow this sequence as
if it's always and then you stick the
results together it's correct and so I
say this sequence splits it's a compound
of two atoms or elements and it turns
out that there are precisely 92 common
elements in this thing and you know that
92 historically there were 92 common
elements in the world and that just took
my fancy there's no connection
whatsoever and but I call these elements
hydrogen helium lithium beryllium boron
carbon
Jim oxygen himself and all the way
through the uranium yes this sequence of
length 10 is not an element it's it's
the compound of this sequence 1 1 1 3 2
and the sequence 1 3 2 1 1 in that if
you follow the let's call as L and R if
you follow L and follow our
independently you still get the right
answer
you only need to consider elements that
aren't compounds or sequences that hunt
compounds and we call those elements or
atoms and it turns out there are 92 of
them I mean you can do various other
things for instance I gave a lecture on
this in Acadia University in Nova Scotia
there was this Nobel Prize winning
physicist David Park at the lecture and
he said what do we ever thought about
Roman numerals one one one oh this is
two one this is three once now this is
for once and the Roman numeral for four
is IV and then this is 1 1 1 5 1 1 this
guy gives rise to another problem of the
same kind and it turns out that this
depends on the use of a twentieth degree
equation